again we're not even at our final top
eight please don't do that to us
anyway party wolf right kill a guy I
watched him personally
Big Boss real okay I didn't act that I
didn't see it but we're still gonna do
it I put up make sure party wolf does it
because we went on this buff killing
crusade and a little Fiat game toppled
right now look at that face
that look like a wolf who came to party
I don't think so we'll see I mean I feel
like we has to have a reason to party
right and if you're in the LCQ if not
even it's a big topic yet no reason to
party it oh great look right now and the
young boy from Iowa he's grown two and a
half inches every time I've seen him
it's fun true I swear he was like 12
yesterday now he's all like 19 or
something and then he was shorter than
me and now I look up to his chin it's
ridiculous but at the rate that these
kids are growing I used to think it was
the food but I think it's these fighting
games man don't think up difficult gods
for the future as you look across all
titles there it's like a little look
look at the Namco title there it's ain't
people just pop it up left and right
they grow up right before our eyes
anyway so we're gonna get ready for this
matchup whitter side of our Tomkinson
stage of history party wolf and enrich
six going at it
we hurt Maxie so rich six propoganda
Maxie party wolf maybe go kill a guy
with a suit that's a safe assumption
anyways we're gonna go to the matchup
right now look at the focus I'm strapped
it yep that's what we thought
Killick in mexico this stage has not
really been popping up throughout the
tournament but this stage is very very
interesting because of the that wall
that briggs after he hit a few times
yeah we had a situation with a tomahawk
got the hit on the wall and just poke it
completely and one sequence and it got
the ring out it was just disgust that's
I mean that's at stage two stages
disgusting look at that big old eye the
background I'd rather not I'm just gonna
keep focus here before I fall into some
type of trance it's not like that anyway
you already level you already that was
just what week I was hypnotized anyway
token I'm trying to fight his way to the
wall gonna hit him with the wiggle stick
back-to-back-to-back gonna drop him down
though that's a lot of stunts he is
working on that guard gates here in
round one party wolf though walked out
to here but he doesn't need it because
he gets to follow up all the splat rich
sticks yeah rich doing a great job of
closing out that round
both please close to having one meter
there goes party wolf call it up counter
hit stand him up able to get out of it
yeah you don't want anything to do with
that we're gonna step up out of it try
not to flip back Wow went great flash
accept it look back to getting this
weird like sad serve back turn thing
instead he's just gonna eat a CD for his
troubles look clean it out and look at
that tied up on rounds out
all right here round up the three we're
gonna break the tie who's gonna take
three sticks has been doing pretty good
offensively here but you know party will
be able to find some holes in his
offense Oh Ben as soon as I see that
about a hole in his hey big hole right
there try to throw something out four
bags range but listen to another new
talk who are very limited range booms
away who backs he pulls that body he can
finesse anybody with a lethal from any
position on the screen how about a seee
for your troubles no now yes still very
blue these guys trying to fight you know
just throw clean keep it in the ranks
it's almost like this flight is just
like sanction section by the Nevada
Board of Fighters sweep maxi coming up
top striking first one that's one yellow
roll out lowdown oh yeah party well for
my big right there looking for a big
better go big right now - let's see what
he does it's dark yeah you have to be
this is no other way okay let me get out
of that don't want any of it
take the health
have faith in his defense in you this
event what you activate soul charge of
this game your character gets access to
a bunch of rooms and a few sequences and
rich they've taken advantage of one of
the better so quick so fast
please don't get counter here buying so
damaging is just stop he was really able
to capitalize on that moment to so rich
takes now up one zero I know
leading party wolf to make a decision
what's he gonna stick with because he
looks like he's so he's sticking with
Killick but again this is a race to two
badges three to find out who's gonna be
getting into our winners final where or
say that's waiting confidently I would
say anyways here we go start of match
number two again rich sticks up one zero
right now party will look for some
openings here but a nice jump over yeah
I imagine says getting ducked off
because we got red on the low oh yeah
this is out he's gone yeah even at that
side angle right a little bit
well back handle back say okay right
this no I don't think I will not this
time party wolf with the sidestep boy
again rich sticks the way he was new
furs around this things with the booze
and
it's just so clean and on top of that
mr. Norvell boom did you come by and all
it's like what are you even go next
the thing is easy has it really tries
any of the low options either he's
trying to open him up and he hasn't had
the need to either okay nice gets the
counter hitting the follow-up pressure
but here we go
Oh what the bad way Oh what's he gonna
do here I had an opportunity and I will
say tell was super soon clutch rich
sticks missing out the first time around
and Cena buddy wolf is taking advantage
to a lot of bad guys anybody trying to
keep the spaces of treatment exactly
where he wants him it's a setup the
rules he wants to paint which takes in
what after he saw it once asking for the
yellow giraffe fantastic movement
fantastic execution yes a good position
especially back to the wall want you to
do here party I'm trying to load up that
car that lethal it puts up it too there
we go see so Todd's
freak attack there try this
was about to speed things up here all
bye oh yes that's gonna hit absolutely
it's gonna be oh it's gonna hurt thanks
for playing
thanks for making that mistake it was a
really good move but not good enough two
rounds to one here party wall all right
take advantage pink stick little stick
as I like to call it - swinging it
around yeah nice duck there and that
entire compilation lei party was just
kind of started missing and I love that
Kristoff's allowing party one to get up
to see what he's gonna do did a lot of
girls like the wake up Musa utilizing
the state no Big Boy launch see II hope
you like cinematic so I'll check this
without hook them up they're tying it up
party book now this comes out of this
this is a big rare absolutely seee
finishes it both on his winning rounds
in this second game here so if you put
him in a situation to get the one hit
that leads into the kill he is good as
gold will he built the feeder in time to
do so those Sam hotel for the whole run
read right there boy ristic that's gonna
sidestep not gonna risk it at all
thanks get some run counter the
follow-up he does he was so close yet be
careful nice block block yeah absolutely
it's X on this time and party wolf with
the scramble ring yeah just kind of
rolled off the side there I don't even
think mystics is ready for by the time
you can react to what was happening he
was taking a splash and white game 2-1
you know what time it is you know what
you came here for right place right time
right place rights had that hit ended up
just working out so well for him crazy
because a party was little stumble there
he he held on to do
don't bring out all right this is the
decisive match here between these two
one of these players will move on to
meet Saint in our winners final yes but
only one of them which stage are we in
so we're taking it to this one all right
we have a low wall we have no walls on
the sides let's find out who's gonna
take the advantage here going for the
quick pokes and quickly sidestepping or
stepping trying to find an opening for
himself able to get the throw this time
yeah after all with Arsenal here goes
for the mix-up oh nice that was old man
spacing right there from our dwarf he
knows their mistake just a boy you know
he's so good you gotta beat a butt like
that was grown man stick a little step
back up to the bait oh that's big to
look at this ball I got something to you
for you - oh man you want to stand there
and re holding great to say that damage
all that red but Haiti happened to get
lethal hit in this game I mean a year
into the game these guys are so optimal
you know from every position every
street here and even though there's
always something to find we go with the
heavy game which takes very very deep
having an opportunity to himself right
now oh here we go pop the sole charge
you know party well flex and steal
rounds if they start killing CDs waiting
for it a little been a proper step
they're able to get the punishment look
at that rich dicks able to take the
route tied up here blast match trying to
beat more--well statistic social
situation so quick nice duck there get
some damage out of it and again Wow
charges it up follow up again again
fishes and I love the optimization from
rich dicks in that situation you saw me
delayed the combo a little bit just to
get in position to get as much corner
carry as possible
looking for the rego not quite enough
but the back throw is gonna get the job
done okay so this is important right now
rich tips one round away from moving on
to our winners finals party won't he's
gonna have to deal with this this is
very important to follow up try this a
little too quick faster to the draw
right back answer in the throat damage
adding up for vaccean rich takes all he
traded blows yeah once you treat
therefore party wolf still in big-time
trouble there's a launch however okay
what's you to do with here what's the
mix-up is he gonna go over guess
there he goes forgive me Maxie is about
to do some crazy stuff he'll do the life
I liked the idea he was looking for the
move did I get the point is just a kiss
to throw this is not gonna do it but put
him in a one hit situation huh final
round
easy fella was easy less situations
there for party wolf one round left
party wolf it's locked and loaded stage
wise here every six gets a big hit he
might be melendi big trouble we're gonna
cancel that keep it on the wall stepping
along side with up here did I step over
not cracking it in situation gets the
lethal hit doesn't have enough no yes
hey to be able throw off all was it
going and looked like an execution error
from party woman it could have been a
setup ain't no telling we could ask him
later but right now both of these men
evenly matched note meter for party wolf
heuristics in position you might be able
to pop pretty soon he can pop at any
time not sure what's the deal he's just
slowing down I think he's just firmly
believes he has it 9 seconds on the
clock soul touched soul charge does stop
it five seconds to use it there so time
is now stopped until the sole charge
beater is gone what's gonna do with it
nice GI oh that gonna be heavy wolf went
for the read on the ricci eye and he
just yep nope yep I did that in a party
wolf fashion smile and a handshake and a
rich Styx AK in the same situation we
saw earlier someone who's never reach
Eid
when he had last hit situation went for
it it seems to be just
cinq Xuan and at this level it's been
baited twice hundred percent ratio party
wolf into the winners final and that was
risky on his old turn she's going for
that guard break opportunity after that
but he ate he had the right read on the
situation he knew that it would work and
he capitalized I mean don't you have to
believe in everything else EQ like you
have to win there's no time for for
maybe or I can download or like later no
this is to get into winners finals right
now and close off a big chunk of that
path because if you lose there you have
like enough three sets to go yeah it's
it's well that's big sometimes your gut
tells you what to do and the head time